Hey Science vs. Fiction-Fans, hey Community.
Der Titel sagt ja schon worum es hier geht… DAS ENDE!
Fünf Jahre haben wir hier mit euch auf dem
Kanal die Physik in Hollywood-Filmen gecheckt,
Promillespiegel aus Silvester-Klassikern
berechnet, den Joker auf die Psycho-Couch gelegt,
mit neurowissenschaftlichem Blick Zombie-Gehirne
erforscht und auch vieles, vieles mehr.
Wir haben dabei echt coole und
verrückte Experimente gemacht.
Wir haben gesungen.
(„Na Na Na – Batman!“)
(„Bella Ciao, Bella Ciao, Bella Ciao Ciao Ciao“)
(„Science vs. Fictionwird heut explain-aligetisch!“)
Und vor allen Dingen jede Menge Spaß gehabt!
Mein Name ist Roland Emmerich und ich mag Videos,
in denen es bummst, kracht und Dinge kaputt gehen!
Endergebnis 112!
Aber es ist doch ein großer Monsterschirm!
Ich sage jetzt nicht Monsterschirm,ich sage einfach großer Schirm!
Und jetzt kommt der Downer.
Science vs. Fiction wird es
ab Januar nicht mehr geben.
Der MDR hat sich dazu entschieden,
das Format nicht mehr weiterzuführen.
Das geht uns im Team allen
sehr nah, mir ganz besonders.
Einfach, weil hier super vier
gemeinsame Arbeit drinsteckt,
aber auch ganz viel Leidenschaft, Energie, Herzblut.
Zeit, die jede Person hier mit eingebracht hat.
Das schmerzt.
Aber es ist jetzt so.
Ich kann nur sagen: Neben den ganzen Live-Shows
ist das eins der coolsten Projekte gewesen,
die ich in den vergangenen Jahren gemacht habe.
Und das nicht zuletzt, weil ihr da mitgemachthabt.
Also eure Kommentare zu lesen
war echt immer schön, weil da so viel
cooles Feedback und so viel Zucker dabei war.
Wir haben das super gern gelesen, es hat uns
mega motiviert. Und man muss sagen, in den ganzen
Jahren gab es wirklich erstaunlich wenig Hate...
...außer bei der Jesus-Folge.
Also danke, dass ihr so nettund konstruktiv gewesen seid. Und deswegen wollen wir euch
gern etwas zurückgeben. Neben einer regulären
Folge, die jetzt im November noch rauskommt,
wollen wir im Dezember noch eine große
Abschiedsfolge machen – als Community-Folge.
Also wir wollen wirklich noch mal
alle möglichen Fragen, die ihr habt,
in eine Folge packen und die beantworten.
Nicht so ausführlich und detailreich
wie sonst - eher so im Speedrun.
Aber dafür noch mal mit ganz vielen
von unseren Expertinnen und Experten,
sowohl aus dem wissenschaftlichen
als auch dem fiktionalen Bereich.
In über 80 Folgen haben wir da ja jede
Menge Leute dabei, die uns was sagen können.
Also haut bitte noch mal alles, was euch
in den Kopf kommt, was ihr schon immer wissen
wolltet, was wir noch nicht beantwortet haben
in die Kommentare unter diesem Video.
Logischerweise was irgendwie mit Film,
Serien und Games zu tun hat.
Wir gucken jetzt eine Woche lang,
was ihr da so fragt, sammeln das und
machen daraus die Abschiedsfolge.
Also bis zum 10.11. könnt ihr hier kommentieren.
Und tut mir dabei bitte noch einen Gefallen.
Wenn ihr jetzt das Gefühl habt, es müssen
noch Leute von Science vs. Fiction erfahren,
dann teilt bitte dieses Video.
Damit wir dann Ende Dezember aucheine richtig coole Abschiedsfolge haben,
diewir mit euch allen gemeinsam mit Live-Chat
als Premierenvideo hier bei YouTube raushauen.
Falls Ihr noch ein kleinen Anreiz dazu braucht:
Wir haben bei uns noch jede Menge Requisiten
aus den ganzen Folgen rumliegen, die wir
gern rausgeben und an euch verlosen wollen.
Weil wir ehrlicherweise glauben,
dass Sie hier im MDR nicht so richtig viel Verwendung finden.
"Da hast du absolut recht!"
Das heißt alle, die unter diesem Video einecoole Frage kommentieren,
nehmen automatischan der Verlosung teil. Und wer dann wirklich
was gewonnen hat, das lösen wir im
Dezember bei der Abschiedsfolge auf.
Wenn ihr wissen wollt, wie es bei mir
persönlich weitergeht, dann freue ich mich,
wenn ihr auf meinem Instagram-Kanal vorbeischaut.
Und ansonsten kann ich bis Dezember nur sagen:
DANKE im Namen vom Team und auch im
Namen von der Redaktion von MDR Wissen.
DANKE für euren Support und falls ihr
es noch nicht gemacht habt,
drückt bitte noch mal abonnieren und auf die Glocke.
Wäre schön, wenn wir noch mit ein paar mehr
Abos aus diesem Jahr rausgehen.
Bis dahin, ciao, ciao.